نتابع مع حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث قالت
سلطات دنياسك المواليه لروسيا ان اربعه
مدنين اصيبوا بجروح في القصف الاوكراني
المتواصله على مدينه ومقاطعه واشارت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت امس خمسه احياء سكنيه
باكثر من 70 قذيفه بينها احياء في مركز
المدينه واضافت السلطات ان القصف الحق
اضرارا ماديه بعده مباني سكنيه
كما نشرت قوه دونيسكا المواليه لروسيا
مقطع فيديو لما قالت انه يوثق لحظه تدمير
اهداف عسكريه اوكرانيه باستخدام طائرات
كاميكاز المسيره الانتحاريه وتظهر اللقطات
المصوره لحظه تنفيذ الطائره المسيره هجمات
على مواقع واهداف عسكريه اوكرانيه
وتدميرها في منطقه بخموت شرقيه البلاد
وسائلوا اعلام مقربه من وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه نشرت مقطع فيديو قالت انه يوثق
الاشتباكات المباشره وسيطره القوات
الروسيه على مواقع اوكرانيه في مكان غير
محدد ويظهر المقطع المصور اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه المباشره على موقع
للقوات الاوكرانيه وقوع قتلى منهم حسب ما
جاء على قناه